bon on a un petit problème de production
d'énergie
le gaz et le charbon ça pollue le
pétrole ça pollue et ça coûte cher en
gros ça fait un moment qu'on sait qu'il
va falloir trouver des énergies
renouvelables est inépuisable
si on veut pas devoir bientôt se
déplacer sur des trottinettes tiré par
des chiens ou s'éclairer à la lueur de
nos déchets nucléaires et vous savez ce
qui est hyper inépuisable le vent
[Musique]
on
ce que vous voyez là ce n'est pas
l'apocalypse nucléaire celle qui
plongera la terre dans un hiver éternel
dans lequel ne survivront que des rares
des cafards et des contrôleurs des
impôts non ce sont des éoliennes oui de
toutes petites éoliennes
rappelons que le principe de l'éolienne
c'est qu'on produit de l'électricité
grâce au vent ce plutôt cool on les
construit désormais au large notamment
en mer du nord où on en col des wagons
entiers sous forme de vaste parc
sauf que l'agencement de ses parcs
modifie la trajectoire du vent en créant
des effets de sciage en gros chaque
éolienne perturber l'écoulement du vent
en le dispersant grâce à ses grosses
pâle et derrière elle il se crée donc un
couloir où le vent ne circulent presque
plus c'est un peu le principe de
l'aspiration en formule 1 si vous placez
d'autres éoliennes derrière elles
fonctionneront donc moins bien
sauf qu'on ne peut pas vraiment se
permettre de mettre une éolienne tous
les 500 km en sait un peu compliqué d'un
point de vue logistique il faut donc les
groupes et mails de manière intelligente
c'est ce que tente de faire nos
chercheurs donc il l'est dispose en
miniature dans un grand bassin tournant
pour étudier précisément ces écoulements
et tenter de déterminer quelles
dispositions et la plus efficace un peu
comme un entraîneur de foot qui
hésiterait entre le 4 4 2 et le 4 3 3
ici l'eau contenue dans le bassin
remplace l'air et simule donc la
circulation du vent et pour voir comment
les courants se dispersent on a bien sûr
tout plein de capteurs ultra high tech
qui prennent des mesures en permanence
mais on a aussi des paillettes
phosphorescente qui permettent de
visualiser les mouvements des courants à
l'oeil nu parce que c'est quand même
pratique d'avoir une vue globale
immédiate et puis aussi parce que les
paillettes c'est super joli
mais ce n'est pas tout le vent ne
s'écoule pas tout droit en fait les
éoliennes sont soumises à des phénomènes
de géophysique de grande ampleur alors
pour bien les implanter sans se planter
il faut faire un peu de physique quand
on passe à échelle réelle il faut tenir
compte de coriolis
la force de coriolis c'est bête comme
chou c'était gala moins deux fois la
masse du corps faut la vitesse angulaire
instantanée de rotation fatale du
produit vectorielle entre le vecteur
unitaire parallèle à l'axé de rotation
et la vitesse relative du corps par
rapport au référentiel en mouvement
voilà bon allez à un super simplifiée
alors mais vraiment pas ce que c'est
vous la force de coriolis c'est un
phénomène qui fait dévier un objet de sa
course logique à cause de la rotation
terrestre exemple si je lâche une balle
depuis le sommet de l'himalaya sa course
ce sera normalement rectiligne à cause
de la gravité sauf que comme l'himalaya
seo le temps que la balle arrive en bas
la terre aura légèrement tourné et donc
la trajectoire apparaîtra comme
légèrement déviée il faut donc en tenir
compte quand on veut prévoir les
mouvements d'objets ou de fluide sur
notre belle planète
bon du coup la force de coriolis
normalement dans votre vie de tous les
jours vous vous en préoccuper peu à
moins que vous ne soyez un tireur
d'élite qui se rend au boulot en chute
libre et qui fait de la météorologie
amateurs le week end mais bon par contre
quand on installe des éoliennes ça peut
servir parce qu'elles sont soumises à
des mouvements géophysique le vent les
courants qu'ils sont eux-mêmes affectés
par la rotation terrestre
pour savoir comment agencer au mieux les
parcs éoliens pour qu'il soit le plus
efficace possible on a donc tout intérêt
à calculer tout ça sauf que prendre des
mesures in situ en mer du nord s'est
franchement la galère c'est pour ça que
notre mini parc éolien on ne va pas
installer dans n'importe quelle piscine
au caire nos chercheurs peuvent compter
sur une structure unique en son genre
la plateforme coriolis si tu fais hall
et j ai dreux noble elle sert aussi à
simuler des zones de tsunamis des
courants marins etc c'est une sorte de
manège trop cool mais pour les gens dont
la passion et la mécanique des fluides
plutôt que les chevaux en bois et la
queue du mickey
construite en 2014 elle attire chaque
année des chercheurs qui viennent du
monde entier pour y mener des
expériences qu'ils ne pourraient pas
faire ailleurs la plateforme coriolis
c'est un bassin cylindrique de 13 mètres
de diamètre d'une masse de 150 à 300
tonnes et capable de tourner à une
vitesse de quatre tours minutes ça n'a
pas l'air comme ça mais en fait c'est
énorme on vous la sueur pour être monté
dessus et avoir galéré à en descendre
ce bassin permet de simuler la rotation
terrestre et donc d'observer la
mécanique des fluides dans des
conditions où tous les paramètres sont
contrôlables du coup les chercheurs
peuvent modéliser expérimentalement les
écoulements atmosphériques et océaniques
et parfois sa demande de mouiller la
chemise et même de se mouiller tout
courts pour modifier les paramètres
manuellement
la manip simulent des conditions
atmosphériques réaliste avec différents
paramètres tout en isolant
spécifiquement l'effet de la force de
coriolis ce qu'on n'avait pas vraiment
pu faire avant puisqu'on ne faisait que
des mesures en soufflerie qui sont peu
fiables ou sur le terrain où les
conditions varient beaucoup et de
manière imprévisible du coup au cours de
plusieurs semaines d'essai on a pu
tester un paquet de configurations
différentes pour voir ce qui entraînait
le moins de perte d'énergie en
réagissant à chaque fois les éoliennes
d'une nouvelle manière
bon pour l'instant les résultats obtenus
par le chercheur venu faire sa manif
d'éoliennes sont surtout des résultats
fondamentaux mais ils ont vocation à
informer les industriels et décideurs
publics au moment d'implanter de
nouveaux parcs éoliens en mer
et ça marche puisque les études menées
grâce à la plateforme coriolis ont déjà
permis d'optimiser l'agencement des
hydroliennes dans les fleuves alors
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à s'occuper
des turbines qui sont au turban pour
nous produire de l'énergie parce que
tant qu'à faire ça serait aussi bien
qu'il serve à quelque chose ces
ventilateurs géants et met d'ailleurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'on mettrait pas des
vrais ventilateurs géants devant les
éoliennes pour qu'elle tourne plus vite
waouh
l'idée est capable de tourner à une
vitesse de tous quatre fait j'ai
l'impression d'être une diseuse de bonne
aventure se lever
[Musique]